so
that was all preamble to explain what
was going on here let's now have a look
at the solution i'm going to start with
part one
this is the easy part you just had to
work out what s3 and s4 were right now
what we get told the data in the
question i'll just write this in a
separate color so that i can distinguish
it
you get told the first term
s1 is 1 you get told that s2 the second
term is 2 and then you get your
recursive formula
these two feed into the fact that to get
all the rest of the numbers you say look
at the previous term s n minus 1
you then multiply the
previous to that term by n minus 1. so
that's why you've got um the previous
term and the one before that okay
so for part one it's fairly
straightforward right we want to say
well s3 is going to depend on s2 and s1
so it's going to be the previous term
plus two lots of the term before that we
know that the previous term was 2 the
first term was 1 so we just get s3 being
equal to 4.
and then you just rehearse that logic
for s4 so you say well it's the previous
term and it's 3 lots of the term before
that so you're going to get we just
worked out as 3 which is 4
and this is going to be 3 lots of 2 so
you get 10 you can see why this is just
one mark okay potentially one of the
easiest marks in any extension to a four
unit exam ever okay
now part two then says what are we
required to prove we need to show
that the square root of x plus x
is going to be greater than or equal to
the square root of x
x plus one and the domain restriction is
for
real numbers for all
i'll just write this for all
real numbers
x
and i think it's just strictly no it's
not actually strictly positive you can't
include zero okay
because of course we can once you put x
equals zero it's just a trivial result
all right how do we do this
now there's a bunch of different ways to
solve this inequality but i think the
most direct way is to notice that
because you've got a square root of
everything on the right hand side of
this inequality what you can think about
is the square of everything there on the
left hand side and the right hand side
and then at the end we can take the
square roots and i'll sort of explain
the logic for that in a second right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
say let's consider
the left hand side squared so that's
going to be the square root of x
plus x
all squared so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to work with this thing and
then towards once my logic is a bit
clearer i can take the square root of
this and i'll have the left hand side
okay
so i'm just going to expand the binomial
this is going to be
square the first let's double the
product in the middle
and then i will square the last there we
go okay but i can say hey hold up you
see this term or this expression rather
here on the right hand side right it's
got an x and an x squared that's what
you have here right this thing
underneath the the square root sign is
x plus x squared so this thing here in
the middle is actually kind of
unnecessary it's not related
i can say though it's bigger right x
times the square root of x since x has
to be greater than or equal to 0
it's going to make this bigger right so
i can say here's my logic i'll put in
another color just so you can see me
reasoning it i can say but
x plus 2 x root x plus x squared that's
clearly greater than or equal to x plus
x squared and i have to tell say y right
it's because
this term here which is the difference
this term here right in the middle
is going to be greater than or equal to
0 because x is greater than or equal to
0 right so at this point i now
transition my equation into an
inequality i can say therefore
take that left hand side
bam over here
and since it was equal to that term
above but now it's going to be greater
than i'm replacing this left hand or
this rather this right hand side with
something smaller okay
so that's that i now go on to the next
step like i said i actually want to
square root sine over everything on the
right hand side which i'll put in place
right now so i'll take the square root
of that
and
i'll just end up with this on the right
hand or the left hand side now why can't
i do this the reason why is because
since
x is going to be real that's why you can
take
every the the square or the square root
rather of everything if we had complex
numbers flying around you couldn't just
make this inequality statement
and also
you need to go back to this because you
couldn't take a square root
if you had for example some negative
thing over here on the right hand side
so um if you had a negative in here you
couldn't take the square root and the
whole thing would just explode uh and
this point we're pretty much done right
i just need to factorize that thing
underneath the square root and i am home
so i'll just take that x out
x plus one
as required
okay
so there was part two like i said um not
many lines are working you just need to
think carefully about how you can get an
expansion that will do the job for you
okay excuse me now here comes the real
um where the rubber really hits the road
as i mentioned in the beginning of the
question okay
we are now required to prove required to
i'll keep it
in the same sort of vein that i've done
before we're required to prove that this
um this sequence any arbitrary sequence
within the term sn
is going to be greater than or equal to
the square root of n factorial um and
everyone looks at that it's like
where did that come from there was
didn't look like there was any
combinatorics or anything like that
within this question factorial is often
weird people out but you're going to see
this is not too dramatic actually we're
going to be able to work with this using
induction and then you can see we get
given this particular set of
restrictions on n it's got to be greater
than or equal to 1 and it's going to be
an integer
okay
now normally i would like to just go
through this question
as normally as i could and then say ah
i'm going to um
yes well spotted emmanuel by the way
sorry there's a few minutes ago i just
didn't notice the chat this is very
similar to a question that appeared in a
previous trial
this question here the twist about this
being let's just go back a second order
recursive formula means that there's
going to be a very significant
difference about the way that we conduct
our first two steps of this induction
right we know how induction works we
test we assume and then we prove right
you test the base case you assume for an
arbitrary case and then you use that as
your foundation for a proof okay
but
you can't do that for a second or order
form recursive formula in the same way
here is why right think about for
example
think about how a normal induction proof
works right when you do the test
and this is for like say for example n
equals 1 then we assume
that the statement is true for n equals
k and then what we do is we prove that
the statement is true for n equals k
plus 1. when you do this normally when
you're proving it for n equals k plus 1
you obviously refer straight back to
your inductive hypothesis right because
you will find the n equals k statement
somewhere
hiding within the n equals k plus 1
statement and that's usually the way
like a lot of your algebraic effort is
to find where that is or to simplify
what you get after you use that result
but because this is a second order
recursive formula when you have a look
at any step like it could be the fourth
or the fifth or the sixth step or the
hundredth step right
you're not just going to look back at
one previous step the whole point of it
being a second order formula is you're
actually going to look back another step
right you're not just going to look at n
equals k you're going to look at the um
the term before that right and so you
need to actually have two successive
terms for um your inductive hypothesis
and because when you're finished right
you're going to say ah because my my
base case works your base case also has
to have two steps in it because any any
arbitrary um
step along the way of your of your
sequence sn has to have the previous two
steps that it can stand upon right so
unlike just going one step at a time
like a normal induction does
this one you have to have your foot
firmly planted on two previous steps so
that means and lots of people missed
this when they were doing this
question in the hsc
that means when we do our test
the first thing i hope all of you
reflexively did was well i'm just going
to test n equals 1. it's not that big a
deal right the left-hand side gives you
1 and the right-hand side the square
root of 1 factorial it also gives you 1.
so therefore yeah it checks out s1 is
greater than or equal to the square root
of one factorial tick but that's not
enough the first
the first n equals one is not enough to
make the base case the base case
actually has to have two things in it
because if you want to progress from
that to go further you need s2 as well
as a minimum right
so therefore i also have to test n
equals two thankfully it is just as
little amount of work you can say well
s2 by definition is 2.
the square root of 2 factorial is the
square root of 2 so like 1.4 ish right
so therefore is 2 bigger than 1.4 is and
the answer is yeah of course it is so s2
is indeed bigger than the square root of
two factorial so tick
now i'm done this these both of these
terms are my base case okay
as i've already mentioned the same thing
is true for when i make my assumption
right and if you only assumed for um for
one thing when you went on to do your
proof you would have been like uh oh
what i do here when i start doing
substitutions you're like i need to go
back another step and you're missing
a term that you can actually substitute
in right so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to say right here that it's not
just true for n equals k
i want to go one more step and then my
proof set will include both of these
right so i mean i could do i could have
gone back one more n equals k minus one
but you know negatives gross um so i'm
just going to go forward and it just
means that when i do my proof step it
won't be k plus 1 it'll be k plus 2 the
next one along okay
so in other words what does your
assumption tell you for n equals k it's
that s k is going to be greater than the
square root of k factorial and for the
other one um the next one over it'll be
s k plus 1 is greater than or equal to
the square root of k plus 1
factorial okay
so that was the big difference from
there i think if you have this
foundation it like if you realize that
this twist has this different
implication for your test and your
assumption you should be pretty okay um
for like i've given you this massive
head start on me so um i hope if you
haven't if you didn't get the solution
yourself in the breakouts you'll be able
to get it now but let me let me talk you
through it